this is from yahoo says a proposal that
took place at disneyland paris has blown
up on reddit and not in a good way
reddit user was gitlan uh initially
posted the proposal video in the i'm a
total piece of s forum and claimed to be
friends with the man who was proposing
and he captured the clip pos destroyed
my best friend's moment he asked for
permission beforehand so okay so in this
video apparently they're at disneyland
paris
uh it's this couple
and the man wants to propose to the
woman
and they're standing in this spot where
apparently people propose all the time
with the little fake castle in the
background well it's a big fake castle
but it is a fake castle uh they they're
they're standing in this the same spot
and and this is and the article goes on
to explain that
that i guess
this is one of the top 10 proposal sites
in the world people go here all the time
to get the instagram proposals
but you're not supposed to stand there
apparently
so in the middle of the proposal
the disneyland employee rushes in and
takes the ring and moves them to another
spot
let's play the video
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
yes that's great but over here she's
gonna be even better
[Music]
um i i gotta say i kind of i'm not a
defender of disney uh by any means
whatsoever but
i'm kind of on the disney police side on
this one i i sort of am
and i tell you why the only reason is
because like it's a proposal
so it's hopefully a once-in-a-lifetime
thing for a lot of people it ends up not
being once a lifetime but but hopefully
it should be
and and so so why are you going
why would you want to go to the place
where a billion other people have done
the proposal it's a top 10 proposal site
so why why do you want to propose in the
most cliche way imaginable so that you
can have the same instagram shot that
that 50 million people also have
so for that reason alone i'm i think
it's they did them a favor
redo the proposal somewhere else if you
feel like you need to make a thing out
of it like do something unique and
interesting
disneyland of all places
a corporate theme park
is where you want to start this journey
with the with the love of your life
that's the real outrage here in my
opinion
hey listen
hit the subscribe button do it right now
i demand it and i thank you for your
compliance it is somewhat appreciated
you